alors on exerce le droit de retrait
aujourd'hui parce qu'on a la goutte
d'eau qui fait déborder le vase on a un
collègue qui en réanimation
là beaucoup de cas qui commencent à se
multiplier dans l'entreprise des classes
suspectés et des cas avérés
on est dans une situation de l'ensemble
des salariés qui étaient là dès trois
heures du matin on était à peu près 150
jusqu'à maintenant on exerce notre droit
de retrait parce qu'on a la boule au
ventre
on n'a aucun masque on n'a aucun moyen
de se protéger on n'a pas de gants en
amont au manque de gel hydroalcoolique
voilà on manque de tout en fait donc en
fait nous avons l'impression tous les
salariés confondus
qu'on nous envoie au front sans fusil et
sans casque
voilà et aujourd'hui on a des personnes
qui viennent acheter des produits qui ne
sont pas du tout de première nécessité
on vient acheter des graines on vient
acheter du théron vient acheter de la
vaisselle on vient se balader parlé au
téléphone
aborder des salariés qui eux sont là
parce qu'ils le sont ils sont obligés de
travailler pour nourrir la population
mais je veux dire on n'est pas là aussi
pour se prendre toute les toutes les
toutes les contaminations possibles de
n'importe qui